okay um I just wanted to come up and ask
like why there's so much mistakes in
your Bible despite that there's a topic
unfortunately your Quran confirms a book
full of mistakes I guess so you can't
answer the question I just did no you
didn't yeah your Quran confirms a book
full of
mistakes okay what did I ask you you ask
me why does the Bible have so many
mistakes in it yes and your answer is
and my answer is well I guess the Quran
is affirming a book full of mistakes no
not an answer no no no you should answer
pertaining to the question my question
is tell me how I should answer Habibi
because it's a two coqu it's a fous
answer because qu yes you know what a
two Co Quay is I didn't I didn't say
well your Quran has many problems in it
I say that okay I'm just I'm just
showing you that if you're going to have
this position then you have a then you
have a problem I'm not affirming that
it's a problem in my in my book but if
if if you're going to be consistent then
you have a terrible position my guy so
what why don't we discuss yours and then
we can go to mine I don't know why we
have to go on you mean discuss mine and
then go to yours you're saying that the
Bible has many mistakes yes you're
saying that as a Muslim so as a Muslim
you're saying that Allah made mistakes
by confirming a book full of mistakes
great we can get to that uh we can get
to that proposition after deal with the
actual issues can we deal with the the
CR the Crux of the issue this is the
Crux of the issue my friend Habibi the
Crux of the issue is that you as a
Muslim cannot in your right mind say
that the Bible has mistakes because your
God says that it's true you're okay so
if it says that it's true then you know
Islam is false so CL us okay can you
show me get them logic you better not
play with him bro go ahead don't play
with him one second one second I want to
see you know who this is on stage man
give me the verse give me the verse what
that confirms the Bible that we have
Today Chapter 2:41 okay let's let's go
let's go to it okay here let's see it
believe in my Revelation my my
Revelations which confirm your
scriptures do not be the first to deny
them or trade them for a fleeting gain
and be mindful of me now what do you
understand from this I I understand that
the Quran says that the scriptures they
have is true in the 7th Century great
now is this in totality yes it says what
is with them it doesn't say part okay
well actually chapter 5:48 gives us a
criteria of that of what is true and
what is not true okay let me show you
how chapter 5:48 says we revealed to you
oh Prophet this book with the truth as a
confirmation of previous scriptures and
supreme authority on that it doesn't say
supreme authority it says what okay what
does MIM what does miman mean m means
Supreme no it doesn't it means Guardian
okay teach me what MIM means mam has
different meaning I just told you I just
told you what it means hold on let me do
this for you give me give me one second
okay you ready give me one second
perfect perfect get ready for the word
for word translation guys toook so you
know it says M when you go to the Corpus
you mean the word for word translation
yeah the word for word does say that
yeah oh so I don't have to show it yeah
but the word for word is not credible in
the Arabic language what do you mean
it's not credible because the word for
word translation actually minuses the
context no it doesn't if it does I can
prove it many versus it doesn't do this
here yes it does actually M has
different meanings you think it has one
concrete meaning you think
no when you when you read tabari YF Ali
J Ali oh my
goodness is that all you heard I said YF
Ali
Kur yeah they talk they all say that
it's it's a witness over Guardian
protector yes and and all of those are
meaning for mamad right and supreme same
exact category and the issue the issue
is is that you're grasping on the straw
that has no bearing on the argument
because the next sent SCH no no no no
okay I didn't say that was grasping on
the straw grasping the straw in the
sense that you are saying that it's a
mistranslation when it has nothing
transation I said it means muham I mean
a guardian okay so this translation
wrong that I'm reading yes okay so it is
a m transation yes it is now I'm saying
it okay thank you you literally implied
that and because when you say that it's
a when you say that supreme authority is
wrong you're implying that it's a wrong
translation
therefore it is a false translation
according to you you're grasp yeah yeah
you're grasping you're grasping on the
wrong straw because the next sentence is
what refute you because it says because
it says judge between GL you mentioning
context us I like you I like you
sometimes man you're you're pretty good
we can get from point A to point B go
ahead though yeah because you grasped on
the wrong Str it's just you know you're
Clinging On to nothing the next sentence
says so judge between them by what God
has revealed for judge between who judge
between them the scriptures no no no no
it's not
it's not them the scriptures like read
the next line what what is them then can
you tell me I'm about to tell you read
the next line by what Allah has revealed
keep going and do not follow their
desires over the truth come to you whose
desires books have desires wait one
second you made a claim can you
substantiate yeah I am do books have
desires can you substantiate your claim
I I am an ask please answer I'm trying
to do books have desires you made a
claim and you're not substan oh come on
yeah books books can have desires yeah
books can have desires listen you said
books can have desires yeah they they
can have desires within them wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait you're not
you're not addressing what wait wait
wait wait a second wait life are you
here life get back over here man don't
leave the live up to me I'm chilling get
back over it says judge between them
referring to the scriptures because the
previous ref because it it continues to
say judge between them by what by what
Allah has revealed to you and do not
follow their vain desires books have
vain desires okay logic so this is going
to be very simple the sentence we read
first it says we revealed to you Prophet
this book question one second the same
you're gonna wake me up I already
respectfully I already answered that
question read right here it says we
raled to you so so let's I don't mean to
cut you off but let's we have we have to
we have to do this you said that books
have desire
what did I mean by that you you said
books have do you know what desires are
okay I'll Grant to you now the issue is
with your argument is you keep grasping
on to straws that don't exist because it
has no bearing on the argument let's say
books don't have desires what is that
going have desires what does that how
does that because I'm reading I right
here I'll show you what it means man
what it means is this is why cuz you
said context which I'm glad you brought
up the context shows you that when what
they're judging between them is between
the people don't follow their vain
desires the people right so don't listen
to them don't follow their vain desires
that's so so this is these these are a
couple of understandings one is that the
Quran will for the for the Muslims tells
you as a Muslim what is lawful for you
and what is what is what is abated from
the previous scriptures upon you and
what is lawful for you now right yeah
that's that's that's that's one
understanding of it and then two judging
between their vain desires using the
Quran to show you what like like the
people not the books themselves man so
why does agree with me then what does he
say okay let me read it to you here
narrates with a I'm going to read it
right here he says and over it means
entrusted over it according to suf who
narrated it from from from himself I
reported that said is the trustworthy
Allah trustworthy over every Divine book
that preceded it that was reported
from said now listen to this the Quran
is trustworthy over the books that
preceded it therefore whatever in these
previous books confirms to the Quran is
true and whatever disagrees with the
Quran is false okay so it does give you
the criteria correct no the Quran the
Quran does it are you serious can I who
is can I can I can I respond to what you
said oh my God you just asked me why
does I why does agree with your position
and I didn't say that he didn't I never
denied that he did right um I'm actually
familiar with it because there's
position on the previous scriptures
which other people disagree with him on
but you very little but okay no it's not
the very little he he will be on one
spectrum and other Scholars will be on
another Spectrum i c brings this up so
if you have um iier that's saying you
know with the position that you just
showed that doesn't give any bearing on
me to the verse because if I was here
I'd cook him too and ask him the same
questions and show have him provide the
evidence from the scripture from the
text of what he's saying instead of
making stuff up the text here the text
the text here says judge between them
and do not follow their vain desires
that's not talking about books that's
talking about people no I I believe that
these two are referring to do two
different things I can retract the part
that that's talking about desires I
don't I really can retract because it
has no bearing upon the argument because
here it says one second wait I'm sorry
he said you're retracting what yeah I'm
retracting the part that because it has
no bearing upon the argument when I
select the book of desires I can retract
because it has no bearing upon the
argument it does upon the argument no it
doesn't it doesn't at all because when
we read here gives the interpretation of
so judge between them by what Allah has
revealed and do not follow their desires
over the truth that has come to you
whose desires one second that sentence
it's referring to two different things
that's number one whose desires brother
the people nice so I was right about
that so do not follow how does that yeah
yeah the desires part is about the
people then when it says wait one second
one second but before it said anything
about the desires that's referring to
the books okay when it says judge
between them by what Allah has revealed
to you and do not follow their vain
Desir still talking about the same them
no talk about people bro no that's not
even what says are all actually
inter one second you see it you see it
as if it's the same thing but it's not
because it says right here so judge
between them by what Allah has revealed
this this is referring to the scriptures
then it says and do not follow their
desires over the truth that has come to
you now this is referring to the people
all right so what what are the people of
the Gospel supposed to use as their
judge it depends in what context in the
same context dude yeah in general fact
keep reading the verse 5 verse 47 keep
reading the keep reading 48 can you can
you address what I'm saying please think
you're I am what you're saying what are
you addressing because because you're
trying to say that Muslims judg use the
Quran to judge the previous scriptures
what's true and what's false so I'm
addressing that particularly you this is
telling this is telling you what you're
supposed to judge by I'm not saying even
saying that you're right but let me let
me just grant you this just for the sake
of argument let me Grant you this what
are the people of the Gospel supposed to
use as their judge okay so now now let
let me answer the question this is a
fallacy very known well by the name of
Shifting the goalpost because your
original argument is not shifting at all
just okay can I demonstrate how without
you interrupting please you're not even
answering the question can I can I it's
a fallacy and I have to point it out
just please just get on the mute button
for one second not answer the question
you can't answer a fous question I agree
you cannot answer a fous question just
question the Quan say that the people of
can can I can I prove how it's a fallacy
without you talking anas just answer
no I'm going to address your policy
first okay thank you so I don't know he
just disappeared he said
okay as you see I don't have a problem
engaging with the dude just answer
honestly man stop running around and and
all these F little claims yeah I I
actually like talking to him until when
until he starts doing that until he
starts doing that it was cool until he
starts doing that stuff bro he's he's
he's not bad he's not bad he just once
he hit that brick wall it's like all
right you got to go if you want to if
you want to come up again you can come
up but answer the question if I'm going
if I'm going with your argument the
Muslims are supposed to use the Quran as
their judge okay what are the what are
the people of the Gospel supposed to use
as their judge oh that's a fallacious
question
how I'm following your logic anas just
answer the question you can't you can't
you can't answer a fous question no no
an so I I enjoy having you here but when
you start hitting that brick wall and
start acting like you don't know what
definitions are start acting like you
can't answer simple questions that's
when it becomes a problem okay you think
it's a problem because you're not
understand what I'm saying you can't
answer fallacy we understand everything
what you're say everything you're saying
can you answer fallacy do you guys
believe you can answer fallacy why don't
why don't you answer the question and
then tell
us fous or whatever no I have to address
a I can't answer a felicious question
that's impossible okay okay watch this I
need one more chance look this is how
you do it I can't answer a felicious
question okay I'll I'll answer it for
you I'll answer it for you I'll answer
it for you logic what was the question
the question was since he's saying that
according to the verse Muslims are
supposed to use the Quran to judge the
previous scriptures and to judge people
what are the people of the Gospel
supposed to use as their judge good the
questions answer I can't answer you see
how easy you see how easy that was to
answer life you answered it because you
don't understand the fallacy can I
explain how it's a fallacy you answer
the question AAS is unable
heuck he get stuck in his own argument
he he cries fallacy fallacy fallacy no
it's cuz you have you a it's not hard to
say what your Quran says and then
explain how it's a fallacy can I prove
it's a fallacy without you talking can
you answer the question you can't answer
felicious question breaking news logic
all right thank you all right well yeah
we'll have yeah we'll have to check back
with you no problem they we'll have to
check back you cool off you're running
logic you can't you
can't you maxed out you get to a limit
and then you max out you got stop doing
that we we're going to show you one more
time how easy it is to answer a question
hey life the Muslims are supposed to use
the Quran to judge the previous
scriptures and judge the people vain
desires what are the people of the
Gospel told that they're supposed to use
as their judge the book that was
revealed to them which was what the
Torah and the inel oh wow wow you answer
the yeah yeah fallacy now now let me
explain how that's a fallacy boom that's
how you do it don't just oh it's a
fallacy I can't answer like bro just be
just say what your book says and then
explain how it doesn't fit in according
to you it's it's simple we we'll let you
do that cuz you're going to you're going
to make yourself not make sense
eventually but you know when you uh when
you choose to not answer the question it
just becomes a problem